das klingt hoffnung stiften deswegen
auch die karte der hoffnung und viele
wagen ja jetzt schon auf zu träumen
träumen also dass das normale leben
wieder zurückkommt und einen traum
natürlich für viele fußball fans endlich
volle stadien endlich mal wieder das
leben genießen endlich mal wieder den
verein anfeuern was glaubst du wie
wahrscheinlich macht solche träume diese
karte der hoffnung also sie lässt auf
jeden fall die fußball fans träumen das
ist ganz klar mit blick auf viele
entscheidungsträger bei uns in der
politik habe ich große sorge dass die
stadien aufgemacht werden aber
angesichts der zahlen die wir haben kann
man eigentlich nur sagen macht die
stadien auf macht die stadien auf macht
die stadien auf und warum sage ich das
auch so deutlich weil es auch studien
gibt die ja ganz klar belegen dass
stadien kein pandemie treiber sind die
gibt es aus großbritannien diese studien
die gibt es auch aus den usa und dort
wird ganz klar gemacht volle stadien
gerade wenn sie nach oben hin offen sind
also auch ganz viel frische luft dort
rein kommt sind kein pandemie treiber
das heißt es ist nicht erklärlich warum
in deutschland bei so guten zahlen
verhältnismäßig guten zahlen die wir
jetzt haben die stadien weiter
geschlossen sind also aufmachen
aufmachen aufmachen ist die devise ganz
klares plädoyer ganz klare forderung von
unserem bild politik chef jan schäfer
hierbei bild live die menschen stehen
dicht gedrängt an der frischen luft an
der pcr test station aber dürfen genauso
dicht gedrängt aktuell noch nicht ins
fußballstadion du wirfst genau dafür
aber wie sehen sie das zuhause unsere
zuschauer macht die stadien wieder voll
hier spricht das volk
[Musik]
also mit den 750 750 zuschauern im
stadio ist ja wohl ein witz hat kann ja
wohl nicht sein also andere schade man
guckt nach england liverpool gestern
gesehen hat volle hütte also da kann man
nicht ein bisschen anders regeln also
wie gesagt mit mit 2g und plus und 750
zuschauer dann ist ein bisschen
abschalten also da kann man locker mal
10.000 die man auf
51.000 verteilen könnte aber das ist ja
wohl ein witz also ich war das letzte
mal im stadion im februar 2020 und es
ist schon sehr sehr lange her dass ein
jetzt zwei jahre und mein herz brennt so
legen wir jetzt seit anfang mitte der
70er jahre bin jetzt schon über 20 jahre
mitglied und habe seit über 30 jahren
dauerkarte egal wo sechs gespielt
dagegen natürlich appellierte natürlich
auch die politik die steigen wieder
aufzumachen wenn es bloß für gewissen
teil ist weil ist es eine
freiluftveranstaltung die ich persönlich
bin jetzt drei mal geimpft also ich sehe
da keine probleme warum ich nicht ins
stadion gehen dürfte für was im film
dann wenigsten wenn ihr doch sowieso ein
geschenk bin ins stadion gehe ich jetzt
seit 40 jahren klassisch mit meinem opa
an der hand gewesen und seitdem vom
lügen wir uns nicht mehr losgekommen es
tut mir sehr weh dass ich nicht rein
kann auch morgen nicht so einen
sensationellen pokalabend
habe mich eigentlich drauf gefreut dass
es wieder mit ein paar zuschauern
wenigstens möglich wäre aber
wie man weiß geht nichts wird also für
mich sehr sehr schlimm da kann ich fast
nicht dass kein nicht steigern weil es
ist
katastrophe einfach
so ein tolles stadion und wir haben die
besten fans glaube ich in deutschland
und jetzt kommt so ein gegner und schau
dir einfach es ist
schade wenn du dich wenn du hier sind
bei normalen spielen und im biergarten
sitzt während ein spiel wo er auch ein
paar sitzen und sich das spiel anschauen
dann hörst du gehörst du schon bevor im
fernsehen das tor fällt fast zum stadion
die leute schreien das ist natürlich
hier jetzt eine gespenstische atmosphäre
hier zehn meter von mir entfernt sind
die kabinen der mannschaft die fahren
von hier aus dem bus 200 meter ins
stadion vor also auf die toten kilometer
in dem fall
schon sehr skurril mannschaft ist
abgeschottet wenn die kommt die fans
dürfen nicht an die mannschaft heran
aber eigentlich sehr
direkt vis á vis fast im selben gebäude
es ist schon sehr skurril und wie gesagt
hier ist dann alles voll ich will nicht
sagen dass soll ich sein das muss sein
weil wir brauchen diese umsätze wir sind
die letzten jahre gut gebeutelt gewesen
aber natürlich ist das ein bisschen
komisch wenn man vor allem wenn man hört
dass cola in
dem bereich wenn schlimme ist draußen
überhaupt nicht also schwierig
das will ich klar die fußballfans die
wollen natürlich zurück ins stadion wir
sehen auch nicht wirklich gründe dafür
dass man die stadien nicht aufmacht was
ist überhaupt der grund sehen die
politik an führt jan schäfer bei uns
noch im studio die stadien nicht zu
öffnen man hat ja gemerkt diese
leidenschaft die bei fußballern herrscht
dort ist pokaltag morgen ist der
dfb-pokal tag also zwei fußballtage in
die deutschland jetzt rein steuert und
die fans dürfen nicht in die stadien was
sind die gründe stadien besucher oder
fußball an sich das ist ja ein großes
fest mit symbolcharakter und politiker
wissen ganz genau ganz ganz viele
millionen deutsche schauen in die
stadien schauen was dort passiert und
wenn die stadien leer sind hofft
zumindest die politiker da hat das auch
viele implikationen auf das normale
verhalten der menschen haltet euch
voneinander fern geht nicht hin aber es
am ende auch ein eingeständnis des
versagens also diese symbolpolitik die
hier betrieben wird die soll versagen
auch in gewisser weise kaschieren und am
ende muss man sagen das verbot in einem
freien land muss eigentlich immer die
ausnahme sein freiheit ist der
normalfall das heißt der besuch im
stadion das muss der normalfall sein und
nicht das verboten das müssen wir uns
eigentlich immer wieder vor augen führen